i
[Música]
el senado de eeuu discute revisiones
para poner más restricciones sobre la
compra de armas luego del tiroteo en una
escuela de texas que ha sido el más
mortífero en casi una década mientras
que el presidente joe biden afirmó que
viajará en los próximos días al estado
rusia continúa atacando el este y está
cada vez más cerca de severodonezk una
de las dos ciudades de la provincia de
lugansk que siguen en control del
gobierno ucraniano por su parte el
kremlin afirmó que reactivará el puerto
de mariupol la ciudad más grande bajo su
poder 'tenemos recordó desde quién
los indígenas ecuatorianos ganaron el
premio goldman que es conocido como el
nobel ambiental
ellos son álex licitante y alexandra
narváez los jóvenes del pueblo nativo
hay co fans fueron reconocidos por
proteger sus territorios amazónicos de
la minería de oro
bienvenidos a las noticias en france 24
los saluda maría clara calle iniciamos
en eeuu pues el tiroteo que hubo en una
escuela en texas el pasado martes sigue
provocando indignación el ex senador
demócrata de tobruk enfrentó al actual
gobernador de texas por su inacción ante
la masacre mientras que el presidente
joe biden anunció que irá a la zona y le
pidió a los estadounidenses que se
enfrenten al gran lobby de las armas que
evita la prohibición de la venta en eeuu
andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
el tiroteo de texas ha reavivado una
disputa de larga data sobre el control
de armas en eeuu un estado abiertamente
proarmas reseñó así lo que ocurrió antes
del tiroteo el stand de información de
weston en el beas hasta este momento la
única información que se sabía de
antemano fue publicada por el pistolero
en facebook aproximadamente 30 minutos
antes de llegar a la escuela
de flores para las webs
la primera publicación fue el punto dijo
le voy a disparar a mi abuela la segunda
publicación fue le disparé a mi abuela
la tercera publicación tal vez menos de
15 minutos antes de llegar a la escuela
decía voy a disparar en una escuela
primaria escobas and winding en el
momento
tras su intervención el ex congresista
demócrata de terror que enfrentó al
gobernador acusándolo de no hacer nada
al respecto de la masacre los policías
respondieron fuertemente lo expulsaron
de la sala
tras el incidente aseguró a los
periodistas que se les debe una acción a
los padres y que es culpa de todos no
sólo de los republicanos seguir
aceptando estas acciones el presidente
estadounidense joe biden anunció su
visita a la zona
gilio viajaremos a texas en los próximos
días para reunirnos con las familias
hacerles saber que tenemos una idea sólo
una idea de su dolor y espero llevar un
poco de consuelo a la comunidad en
estado de shock dolor y trauma
bailén también renovó sus críticas al
lobby de las armas en eeuu que lucha
contra los intentos de imponer
regulaciones más estrictas a esta
industria la poderosa asociación
nacional del rifle culpó de la masacre a
un criminal solitario y trastornado y se
espera que el viernes se realice la
convención anual que reunirá entre otros
al ex presidente de donald trump
y a propósito del debate entre la
regulación de venta de armas en eeuu y
el poder que tienen organizaciones como
la asociación nacional del rifle
previamente hablamos con andy pelosi él
es director ejecutivo de bailes policy
center nos explicó algunas de las
razones por la que ha sido tan difícil
restringir la venta de armamento en el
país incluso después de tiroteos
escuchamos lo que nos dijo desde nueva
york
desafortunadamente tenemos 315 millones
de armas en manos de civiles en eeuu
y eso nos hace pensar que somos uno de
los países más seguros del mundo pero no
lo somos el lobby de armas en eeuu tiene
un real dominio sobre muchos políticos
especialmente en washington dc sword una
de las principales razones para que no
veamos cambios reales desde la tragedia
de sant dijo en 2012
pasamos a noticias de ucrania las tropas
rusas alcanzaron las afueras de
severodonezk una de las dos únicas
ciudades que aún resisten en la
provincia de lugansk aunque los ataques
y los bombardeos de rusia en esa región
han aumentado su avance es lento y
todavía no controlan totalmente la
región mientras que las autoridades
locales afirman que los rusos aún no se
apoderaron de la vía que conduce a bach
mut conocida como la capital militar de
donges por su conexión por tierra con
lugares que aún están bajo el poder
ucraniano por su lado moscú afirmó que
el puerto de mariupol
a funcionar con normalidad después de
que desactivaron más de 12.000
artefactos explosivos que estaban
sembrados en la costa recordemos que
mariupol es la ciudad más grande que ha
capturado rusia hasta ahora en ucrania y
en otros territorios controlados por
ellos here soon is a polilla el kremlin
anunció que le dará pasaportes rusos a
los habitantes nuestra enviada especial
catalina gómez ángel nos explica desde
kiev cómo ha cambiado la estrategia
militar de rusia
la guerra nuclear han entrado en el
cuarto mes con una realidad muy
diferente a la que empezó entonces aquel
24 de febrero cuando el presidente
vladimir putin anunció el inicio de esa
operación especial que terminaría siendo
por lo que era una invasión y una guerra
se creyó que esta operación empezaría
por el donbass por esa zona de las
provincias de luhansk y de dones no fue
así realmente esa gran ofensiva comenzó
por el norte del país camino a donde
estamos a la capital kiev con una gran
caravana de tanques y con grandes
ataques a esta ciudad donde las personas
no solamente evacuaron por miles y por
millones sino que también vivían en esos
refugios e incluso en el metro de la
ciudad después de una contraofensiva de
las fuerzas ucranianas las tropas rusas
se retiraron por orden del presidente
vladimir putin y comenzaron semanas
después esto que se llamó la segunda
fase ahora si las tropas fueron a la
zona del donbass donde se libra
actualmente una de las grandes batallas
especialmente en perdón es la segunda
ciudad de la provincia de luján que
actualmente está asediada atacada y
bombardeada constantemente por las
tropas rusas hoy logró entrar casi
milagrosamente una misión humanitaria
que logró sacar a algunas personas que
querían evacuar pero los llamados de
atención sobre lo que pueda pasar sobre
en esta ciudad son bastante grandes se
creen que podría convertirse en una
nueva mariupol como también ha llamado
la atención el presidente ucraniano pro
2000 selenski
durante cinco horas funcionarios de
suecia y finlandia conversaron con sus
homólogos turcos en ankara en un
esfuerzo para que turquía no se oponga a
la candidatura de los nórdicos a la otan
el presidente reyerta y berbegal acusa a
los suecos y a los finlandeses de darle
armas y dinero al partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán pkk de
turquía considera terroristas sin
embargo tras el encuentro hay actitudes
positivas veamos
las delegaciones sueca y finlandesa
volaron ankara para las conversaciones a
tres bandas con turquía fueron recibidos
por el portavoz del presidente recep
tayib erdogán y su viceministro de
asuntos exteriores el objetivo de esta
reunión y de las siguientes es abordar
las preocupaciones de turquía en materia
de seguridad tras las solicitudes de
ingreso de finlandia y suecia a la otan
ankara acogió con satisfacción un primer
diálogo positivo
hemos visto una actitud positiva hacia
el levantamiento de las sanciones contra
los productores de la industria de
defensa en esta reunión es un tema
importante que podemos añadir a la
agenda positiva de la reunión
el tema del fin de las sanciones sobre
las armas es sólo una de las cinco
garantías concretas que ankara está
buscando específicamente por parte de
suecia las otras incluyen cooperación
global contra el terrorismo cese del
apoyo político al terrorismo eliminación
de la fuente de financiación del
terrorismo cese del apoyo armamentístico
al pkk y su rama siria gpg en estocolmo
la primera ministra sueca dijo que
quería aclarar los malentendidos durante
las conversaciones con turquía en swing
junto al presidente del consejo de la
unión europea charles michel magdalena'
anderson refutó las afirmaciones de
ankara de que suecia apoya grupos
militares kurdos
no enviamos dinero a organizaciones
terroristas por supuesto ni armas
turquía también exige la extradición de
unos 28 presuntos sospechosos de
terrorismo radicados en suecia y en
finlandia la lista de exigencias hace
que se desvanezcan las esperanzas de un
rápido ingreso en la otan para los dos
países nórdicos el primer ministro del
reino unido- boris johnson asumió la
responsabilidad por haber quebrantado
las reglas de aislamiento durante los
momentos más críticos de la pandemia en
el país un caso conocido como el pari
gate y por el cual los organismos de
seguridad han emitido más de 100
notificaciones de sanciones en contra de
funcionarios pero a pesar de que la
oposición le pide que renuncie johnson
señaló que continuará en su cargo les
contamos más en el siguiente informe
acorralado pero firme así luce
actualmente el primer ministro británico
boris johnson luego de que fuese
revelado el informe final elaborado por
la alta funcionaria británica sucre y
que sorprendió a johnson por su
contenido en el que se presentan
fotografías donde se le observa
ingiriendo bebidas alcohólicas junto a
otras personas cuando en teoría todos
los ingleses deberían obedecer las
estrictas medidas por los confinamientos
y siento abrumadoramente que es mi
trabajo seguir adelante y cumplir y no
importa cuan a marcas y dolorosas sean
las conclusiones de esto y lo son tengo
que seguir adelante y el gobierno tiene
que seguir moviéndose hip hop
wow
su grey fue designada para llevar
adelante la investigación sobre el
denominado parque un escándalo que ha
salpicado a la administración de johnson
por una serie de reuniones en downing
street celebradas en 2020 y 2021 en
plena crisis sanitaria por el cob y 19
por aquel entonces a los ingleses del
común no se les permitía siquiera
visitar a sus familiares enfermos
trabajó por más de 20 meses analizando
la situación y entre sus conclusiones
destaca una cultura que permitió
congregaciones festivas que no te dieron
haber ocurrido
83 funcionarios fueron multados entre
ellos el propio primer ministro
convirtiéndose en el primero en
quebrantar la ley mientras ejercen el
cargo
de
ley muchas de las cosas que viene el
informe esta mañana eran nuevas para mí
pero creo que es importante déjenme
decirlo de esta manera creo que es
importante que todos los que se nombran
los que no han sido nombrados o los
involucrados de alguna manera tienen que
aprender la lección
y business
la reacción de johnson no convence a la
oposición su líder kirsch timer aseguró
que las revelaciones del reporte
confirman que el premier trató los
sacrificios del pueblo británico durante
la pandemia con desprecio a los
indígenas ecuatorianos fueron
galardonados con el premio goldman 2022
el máximo reconocimiento ambiental álex
licitante y alexandra narváez lideraron
un movimiento indígena en su comunidad
cofán para que la justicia cancelará 52
concesiones ilegales de extracción de
oro en octubre de 2018 los jueces
fallaron a su favor y así estos dos
jóvenes lograron proteger casi 32 mil
hectáreas de selva tropical en la
amazonía ecuatoriana ellos ganaron el
premio en la categoría de américa
central y del sur otras 5 personas
obtuvieron el goldman en representación
de norteamérica europa asia áfrica y las
naciones insulares miremos lo que ellos
dijeron
y recibir el premio goldman simboliza la
esperanza espero seguir con esta lucha
para cuidar la amazonía y la vida este
premio es un símbolo de la fuerza
colectiva de los pueblos indígenas por
la defensa de nuestro territorio y de
nuestras vidas por el futuro de nuestros
niños
faltan tres días para que termine el
festival de cine de cannes en la semana
que lleva se han exhibido varias de las
21 películas nominadas a la palma de oro
que es el máximo premio lo más destacado
de lo que ocurrió el pasado martes en la
ribera francesa nos lo trae maría
carolina piña la enviada especial de
france 24 nuestra cadena y de nuestra
cadena hermana rf la emoción fue el
común denominador de las cintas que
entraron en la competencia del festival
de cannes
[Música]
cannes es como una segunda casa para los
hermanos belgas jean-pierre y luc
dardenne hace 20 años fundaron un cine
basado en lo real con el que hicieron
las magníficas rosetta y el niño que
ganaron la palma de oro en 2022 están en
la competencia con torii y lo quita
[Música]
pero
i
[Música]
y lo quita es la historia de dos niños
inmigrantes ilegales que vienen de venir
en busca de los preciados papeles para
quedarse en europa los dardenne abordan
aquí la condición de los menores solos
seres humanos vulnerables y abusados de
múltiples maneras
[Música]
todos
el director italiano mario martone está
en la competencia de cannes con
nostalgia una reflexión sobre la
nostalgia de la juventud del país natal
y de la familia
[Música]
tras 40 años en el extranjero feliz se
regresa a su barrio napolitano vuelve
para ver a su madre pero no embargan los
recuerdos y la añoranza del lugar su
presencia termina siendo un estorbo para
un capo local de la camorra quien fue su
amigo de juventud
[Música]
nuestra guía cuenta con la actuación del
magnético pierfrancesco favino
estremecedora en el papel de este hombre
que cree que el tiempo lo cura todo
[Música]
sigan con nosotros